So to give you a more clear understanding about the algorithm that Alice is using,
I'm going to write it down in a sort of pseudo-code.
That means I'm not going to write real Python code or any other programming
language that you're used to but, basically, do a more formal description of this
'trying all possibilities' algorithm.
So the solution that we're looking for is going to be written into a variable
called 'minimum devices.'
And initially to start off the algorithm, we're going to set that variable to the number
of communication centers because that is the maximum number of
monitoring devices that you are going to need in any case.
The algorithm then goes through each assignment of the values 0 and 1 to the
communication centers.
And what I mean by that is a value of 0 means that communication center
does not get a monitoring device, and a 1 means that we are going to install
a monitoring device at that communication center.
The algorithm then checks if the assignment is valid.
And what I mean by valid is that the communication centers that
have a 1 in the assignment are monitoring all the cables in the network.
If we have a valid assignment, the algorithm then computes how many
devices we used in that assignment, which is simply summing all the 1's that are
in the current assignment that we're working on.
The algorithm then checks if the current assignment is a better solution
than the best one we have found so far.
And it does that by taking the minimum of the currently known best solution,
which is 'minimum devices'--here--and the number of devices
in the current assignment.
If you're familiar with algorithms, you might already see a few issues--
even in this pseudo-code--with this algorithm.
But we're going to go into that more deeply in Unit 3, actually.
Right now, we're just going to work with this very simple version here.